let's do a couple of exercises from our
probability one module so we have a bag
with nine red marbles two blue marbles
and three green marbles in it what is
the probability of randomly selecting a
non-blue marble from the bag so let's
let's draw this bag here so that's my
bag and we're going to assume that it's
a transparent bag that looks like a like
a vase but let's we have nine red
marbles so let me draw nine red marbles
one two three four five six seven eight
nine red marble so that looks like kind
of orangish but does the job two blue
marbles so we have one blue marble two
blue marbles and then we have three
green marbles
three green marbles let me draw those
three so one two three what is the
probability of randomly selecting a
non-blue marble from the bag so maybe we
mix them all up and we have an equal
probability of selecting any one of
these and the way you just think about
it is is what fraction of all of the
possible events meet our constraints so
let's just think about all of the
possible events first how many different
possible marbles can we take out well
that's just the total number of marbles
there are so there are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 possible marbles so this
is the number of possibilities number of
possibilities possibilities and then we
just have to think what fraction of
those possibilities meet our constraints
and the other way you could've gotten 14
is just taking 9 plus 2 plus 3 so what
what number of those possibilities meet
our constraints and remember our
constraint is selecting a non-blue a
non-blue marble from the bag another way
to think about it is a red or a green
marble because the only non blue ones
are only other two colors we have our
red and green so how many non-blue
marbles are there well there's a couple
of ways to think about it you could say
there's 14 total marbles to our blue so
they're going to be 14 minus 14 minus 2
which is 12 non blue
marbles or you could just count them 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 so there are
twelve non-blue marbles so that's the
number of non non blue so these are the
possibilities that meet our constraints
over all of the possibilities and then
if we want to this isn't in lowest this
isn't in simplified form right here
since both 12 and 14 are divisible by
two so let's divide both the numerator
and the denominator by 2 and you get 6
over 7 so we have a six seventh chance
of selecting a non-blue marble from the
bag let's do another one if a number is
randomly chosen from the following list
what is the probability that the number
is a multiple of five so once again we
want to find we want to find the
fraction of the total possibilities that
meet our constraint and our constraint
is being a multiple of five so how many
total possibilities are there let's
think about that
total total possibilities possibilities
total possibilities how many do we have
well that's just a number of numbers we
have to pick from so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 so there are twelve
possibilities we have an equal chance of
picking any one of these twelve now
which of these twelve are numb our
multiple of five so let's let me do this
in a different color so let me pick out
the multiples of five 32 is not a
multiple 549 is not a multiple 5 55 is a
multiple of five really we're just
looking for the numbers that are in the
ones place either have a 5 or a 0 55 is
a multiple of 5 30 is a multiple of 5
that's 6 times 5 that's 50 5 is 11 times
not 56 not 28 this is clearly 5 times 10
this is this is 8 times 5 this is the
same number again also 8 times 5 so all
of these are multiples of 5 45 that's a
9 times 5 3 is not a multiple of 5 25
clearly 5 times 5 so I've circled all of
the multiples of 5
so of all the possibilities the ones
that meet our constraint of being a
multiple of five there are one two three
four five six seven possibilities so
seven meet our constraint meet our meet
our constraints so in this example the
probability of selecting a number that
is a multiple of five is seven twelve
let's do another one let's do another
one
the circumference of a circle is 36 PI
let's draw this let's draw this circle
so I let's say the circle looks I can
draw a neater circle than that so let's
say the circle looks something like that
and the circumference we have to be
careful here they're giving us
interesting
so circumference the circumference is 36
PI then they tell us that contained in
that circle is a smaller circle with
area 16 pi so inside the bigger circle
we have a smaller circle that has this
guy right over here has an area of 16 pi
a point is selected at random from
inside the larger circle so we're going
to randomly select some point in this
larger circle what is the probability
that the point also lies in this smaller
circle so here's a little bit
interesting because you actually have an
infinite number of points in both of
these circles because it's they're not
it's not it's not kind of separate balls
or marbles like we saw in the first
example or separate numbers there's
actually a infinite number of points you
can pick here and so when we talk about
the probability that the point also lies
in the smaller circle we're really
thinking about the percentage of the
points in the larger circle that are
also in the smaller circle or another
way to think about it is the probability
that the point is also the probability
that if we were to pick a point from
this larger circle the probability
that's also in the smaller circle is
really just going to be the percentage
of the larger circle that is the smaller
circle I know that might sound confusing
but we really just have to figure out
the areas for both of them and it's
really just going to be the ratio so
let's think about that
so there's a temptation to just use this
36 PI up here but we have to remember
this was the circumference and we need
to figure out the area of both of these
circles and so for area we need to know
the radius because area is PI R squared
so we can figure out the radius from the
circumference by saying well
circumference is equal to 2 times pi
times the radius of the circle or if you
say 36 pi which we were told as a
circumference is equal to 2 times pi
times the radius we can divide both
sides by 2 pi divide both sides by 2 pi
and on the left hand side 36 divided by
2 is 18 the PI's cancel out we get our
radius as being equal to 18 for this
larger circle this larger circle has a
radius of 18 so if we want to know its
area its area is going to be PI R
squared which is equal to pi times 18
squared now let's figure out what 18
squared is 18 times 18 8 times 8 is 64 8
times 1 is 8 plus 6 is 14 and then we
have we put that 0 there because we're
now in the tens place 1 times 8 is 8 1
times 1 is 1 and really this is a 10 x a
10 that's why I guess it gives us 100
then anyway 4 plus 0 is a 4 4 plus 8 is
a 12 and then 1 plus 1 plus 1 is a 3 so
it's 324 so the area here is equal to PI
times 324 or we could say 324 pi so the
area of the entire larger circle the
part that I've shaded in yellow
including what's kind of under this
ordinate that way
this area right over here is equal to
324 pi so the probability that a point
that is that we select from this larger
circle is also in the smaller circle is
really just a percentage of the larger
circle that is the smaller circle so our
probability I'll just write it like this
the probability of that the point is
also lies in the smaller
Circle so all of that stuff I'll put in
the probability of that is going to be
equal to the percentage of this larger
circle that is a smaller one and that's
going to be or we could say the fraction
of the larger circles area that is the
smaller circles area so it's going to be
16 pi over over 324 pi over three
hundred and twenty-four pi and the PI's
cancel out and let's see it looks like
both of them are divisible by four if we
divide the numerator by 4 we get 4 if we
divide the denominator by 4 what do we
get 4 goes into 320 80 times it goes
into 4 once so we get an 81 so the proud
of probability so I didn't even draw
this to scale this this area is actually
much smaller when you do it to scale the
probability that you if you were to
randomly select a point from the larger
circle that it also lies in the smaller
one is the ratio of the area is the
ratio of the smaller circle to the
larger one and that is 480 once I guess
it's the best way to say it